demain retour au sénat en deuxième
lecture du projet de loi d'abrogation et
de révision de la loi sécurité et
liberté
l'intérêt tout particulier de ce
réexamen tient au dépôt d'un amendement
gouvernemental portant sur la
réglementation des contrôles d'identité
un amendement qui dans une certaine
confusion avait déjà opposé le groupe
socialiste au président socialiste de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée à la
demande du président mitterrand lui même
les députés ont décidé de rédiger une
nouvelle fois l'amendement litigieux
dans un sens moins restrictif que celui
qu'ils avaient adoptée en avril
en fait les avatars de cet amendement
illustre bien les difficultés de la
gauche depuis qu'elle est au pouvoir à
concilier son inspiration à libéraliser
la justice et les exigences de la
sécurité publique pire alain retrace les
étapes de ce conflit elle sait bien que
dans la foule
tu as trois treillet au passage de bus
fait de bons temps au tour du palais de
justice alors pu faire un bon temps je
trouve est un jeune homme qui s'appelait
patrick henry croyez moi à ma
stupéfaction quand je l'aï appris j'ai
compris ce que ce jour-là pouvait
signifier la valeur situe à vis de la
peine de mort la peine de mort sera
abolie en octobre 80 depuis deux ans
sous l'impulsion de françois mitterrand
robert badinter incarne avec une
détermination passionnée cette volonté
de rendre la justice plus humaine
les décisions empreinte de libéralisme
voire de générosité se succèdent
amnistie 12,80 plus d'un millier de
détenus en bénéficient
suppression de la cour de sûreté d'état
et des tribunaux militaires
abrogation de la loi anti casseurs et
suppression des quartiers de sécurité
renforcées dans les prisons humanisation
des conditions détention peine de
substitution et cetera
parallèlement les victimes de crimes ou
de délits ne sont pas oubliés la
reconnaissance de leurs droits est
améliorée le tout s'inscrit dans un
projet ambitieux restaurer le plein
usage des droits de l'homme éliminer les
entraves aux libertés individuelles et
collectives avec à la clé une réforme
historique celle du code pénal
datant de napoléon mais les idées les
plus nobles se heurte à l'obstination
des faits qui conduisent à ce phénomène
que deux concepts a priori
complémentaires sécurité et liberté
deviennent antinomiques
c'est bien connu la sécurité des uns
commence là où s'arrête la liberté des
autres
le 29 mars 82 alors que robert badinter
prépare le projet abrogeant la loi
sécurité et liberté d'alain peyrefitte
une bombe explose dans le train capitole
5 morts 27 blessés on n'a jamais vu ça
dix jours après pierre mauroy décide de
reporter l'examen du projet de loi tant
il est vrai qu'il est difficile
d'évoquer un assouplissement des
contrôles d'identité quand on les
renforce dans les gares d'autant plus
que l'opinion publique exprime à travers
des sondages son inquiétude devant
l'insécurité
un sentiment largement exploitée
politiquement et puis gaston defferre de
faire face au mécontentement des
policiers les obsèques d'un des leurs a
battu par un gangster à lyon prennent
l'alluré d'une véritable manifestation
contre ce qu'ils considèrent comme du
laxisme le 15 avril 82 recevant les
chefs de la police le ministre de
l'intérieur demande que les contrôles
soient renforcés et que les policiers
soient autorisés à utiliser leurs armes
premier coup à l'élan libéral et en même
temps à la cohésion gouvernementale et
d'en donner
d'une part la criminalité la délinquance
le terrorise le nombre de dangers qui en
france la police ne pourra jouer son
rôle préventif qui est un rôle essentiel
qu'à condition de pouvoir faire des
contrôles d'identité très complet et
très régulier badinter s'insurge et
menacent de démissionner les deux
ministres sont convoqués à matignon le
19 avril
le 21 le conseil des ministres désavoue
de fer sur l'usagé des armes mais
renforce les contrôles d'identité
le lendemain même c'est l'attentât de la
rue marbeuf une passante et tué puis en
août
la fusillade dans un restaurant juif rue
des rosiers six morts 22 blessés après
avoir nommé entre les deux attentats une
commission sur la sécurité dans les
villes le gouvernement s'enrichit le 17
août d'un secrétaire d'état à la
sécurité
joseph francheski à ce stade on ne peut
parler de revirements en matière de
liberté et de justice
le projet d'abrogation de la loi
persiste est adoptée en juin soumis aux
députés en juillet 82 mais il faudra
presque un an avant que les sénateurs
examinent en avril 83 paradoxe cette loi
qui interdisait toute prise de photos et
d'empreintes digitales à l'occasion des
contrôles se verra remplacé de navets en
navette et d'amendement en amendement
par une loi socialiste les autorisant le
réalisme du pouvoir conduire est il
fatalement à quelques renoncements
idéologique ou n'est-ce qu'une
malheureuse confusion c'est françois
mitterrand lui même qui doit intervenir
qu'en disque bat l'inter se tait et que
la ligue des droits de l'homme tempête
le projet sera revu et corrigé